vous allez voir les enfants je suis le
roi du colin maillard je vais tous vous
attraper
mais enfin mais où êtes vous
mais laissez vous attrapez voyons
vous vous cachez un moment vous trichez
sayah j'en ai un an j'ai deviné c'est
joli
non
attendez à ces si monsieur du snob allié
alors non
vous avez raison il est trop gros pour
être monsieur du snav c'est mademoiselle
futé
décidément a agi trouver un chapeau
annoncé c'est une casquette une
casquette va alors c'est le facteur et
ontariens
se trouvait khamis a élu le premier coup
non
on vous êtes de mauvaise foi alors je ne
veux plus jouer avec vous allez jouer
qu'au salle
je suis vraiment un persécuté facteur
là pour te consoler casimir jeter à
porter lettre m'a donné à moi tout de
suite elle seconde à temps avant la
voilà à monsieur casimir l'île aux
enfants c'est bien toi mais évidemment
c'est moi ou vous ne me reconnaissez pas
pour pour sûr je plaisantais casimir
tient là voilà allez au revoir et bonne
journée merci au revoir à tous les
enfants voyons voyons voir ça
mon cher casimir
j'ai eu de tes nouvelles par le journal
et cela m'a donné envie de venir peut
voir j'arrive par le prochain bateau ton
cousin albéric à les enfants mon cousin
ibérique vient voir mon cousin ibérique
arrive
il faut absolument que j'annonce est
bonne nouvelle à françois et julie
meco font-ils je voudrais être obligé de
partir si je ne veux pas rater l'arrivée
du bateau salil casimir j'aurais aimé
vous - eh bien ce n'est pas trop tôt tu
nous attendait mais oui j'ai une
nouvelle très importante à vous annoncer
aux casimir j'ai deviné tu ne t'es pas
discuté de la journée avec monsieur du
snob non ce n'est pas ça je sais tu as
moujik iv gouby boulga d'affilée non non
je lis ça n'a rien à voir je vous dis
que c'est une nouvelle extraordinaire
s'est alors dit nous l'a vite
mon cousin amérique vient moreau visible
ici même d'accord beau et bien moi je
veux m'occuper de mes ballons et moi
ouvrir mon kiosque vous n'avez pas bien
compris ce que je vous ai dit j'ai dit
comme mon cousin amérique venez me voir
ici il m'a même écrit regarder la lettre
à aimer ça ne prend pas cette farce cela
ne marche plus mais quand vous
arrive-t-il à tous les deux etes-vous
bas-rhin us ou non mais soyons clairs
casey mears a fait au moins la dixième
fois que du nous annonce la verrait
l'arrivée d'un des membres de ta famille
dans le jardin tu nous a annoncé
l'arrivée de l'oncle archibald de
l'attentât des l'oeil de plusieurs
cousins alors tu comprends nous ne te
croyons plus c'est pas la peine
d'insister
pour une fois que je dis vraiment la
vérité
incroyable pour de toute façon ils
seront bien obligés de même de me croire
quand je vais revenir dans le jardin
avec mon cousin ils pourront pas faire
autrement pour aller il faut que je me
dépêche parce que mon cousin est
tellement timide à 15 lorsqu'il va
arriver s'ils ne me vois pas sur le quai
il est capable de repartir par le même
bateau allait tout à l'heure
julie s'il te plaît tu me donnes vient
de limonade mis certainement laissé du
cerveau tous les clients mais s'y tient
merci dieu on était cinquante centimes
ça fait du bien julie tu ne trouves pas
bizarre que nous l'ayons pas revu
casimir depuis certains c'est tout à
l'heure
je crois pas je sais qu'il est en train
d'essayer sa farce auprès de 29,8 et de
ses dix neuf c'est possible mais moi
j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il nous
prépare quelque chose
et que casimir adore se déguiser et
qu'il pourrait bien revenir dans le
jardin déguisé en cousin algérie
tu as raison julie nous allons lui
préparer une réception spéciale au
travail
voilà je mélange bien la poudre à
éternuer le poil à gratter et les
confettis comme ça ça va être parfait
quant à moi je garde précieusement mon
père du défunt en cachant
bien comme ça
casimir va apprendre le sens du proverbe
tel est pris qui croyait prendre
oui midi voir s'il se déguise pas en
cause al b nous allons avoir l'air mal
avec notre poudre a été relu nos quand
betty et notre huile de foie lui
voilà l'objectif
kazim et au monde et c'est très joli ici
pour son déguisement hôpitaux règne
il est méconnaissable
vous cherchez quelque chose monsieur
monsieur albéric mon nom est albert et
je suis le cousin de casimir mais vous
vous êtes monsieur françois nous mais
bravo vous mais vous avez deviné juste
je vais vous accueillir à la mode de
l'île aux enfants regarder et c'est très
gentils amis des cousins les délits vive
le cousin eric le coz états unis
comme icône arrive et
ça me pique le nez et puis c'est
tout oh oh ne vous inquiétez pas ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est simplement le
l'assaisonnement des confettis que tu
aimes ton de trop riches en en poudre
interne est allée un poil à gratter je
ne savais pas qu'on pouvait assaisonner
les confettis
vous ne saviez pas d'une très vieille
coutume de l'île aux enfants vous vous
boire quelque chose oui volontiers après
tout ça oui oui alors je vous présente
julie voilà
moi c'est affligeant
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler je suis
très flatté de mai buvez
augmenter
les recettes
nous ne te fâche pas casimir casimir
tout à l'heure tu as voulu nous faire
une farce et bien c'est nous qui t'avons
ugly il faut être beau joueur
je ne comprends rien oh non je retourne
chez moi je m'en vais casimir ne soit
pas bête que les murs finissent
quand vous lui voulait à kazimiyah
tu
entendu
une derrière
[Applaudissements]
casimir q qu'est ce que tu fais là eh
bien vous m'avez fait perdre tellement
veut pas tout à l'heure quand je rappais
l'arrivée du bateau mais alors casimir
lui celle d'éric et bien sûr
atterri crois que
casimir à
bouger
[Applaudissements]
le voyage mais alors pessamit
finalement je crois que je m'entendrai
très bien vu
[Musique]